[Music]  the force was strong at the Star Wars  Celebration in Orlando it's all in honor  of the franchise's 40th anniversary  ladies and gentlemen please welcome  Harrison Ford  Harrison Ford threw shade on himself  referencing his recent pilot mishaps he  was a surprise guest Thursday and it's  his first time at the event he got the  part because in the end I said you know  no fly I said fly yeah  land the ethic panel included Luke  Skywalker himself Mark Hamill and a rare  appearance from Anakin Skywalker Hayden  Christensen who was met with a rousing  standing ovation George Lucas took a  moment to pay tribute to the late Carrie  Fisher she warned rushed to the whole  thing but she was the toughest one of  the group and Carrie's daughter Billie  lourd surprised fans when she hit the  stage dressed as Princess Leia to honor  her mother my mom used to say she never  knew where Princess Leia ended and  Carrie Fisher began  you